اخفق البرلمان اللبناني للمره الثانيه
عشره في انتخاب رئيس جديد للبلاد لتعذر
حصول اي من المرشحين على ثلثي الاصوات اذا
اظهرت نتائج الفرز حصولا مرشح جهاد ازور
على 59 صوتا بينما حصل المرشح
على 51 صوتا في جلسه البرلمان لانتخاب
الرئيس وعقد شارك في هذه الجلسه كامل
اعضاء البرلمان البالغ عددهم
128 نائبا وقد رفع رئيس مجلس النواب نبيه
بري الجلسه بعد فقدان النصاب الدستوري في
الدوره الثانيه منها
من امام مقر البرلمان اللبناني في بيروت
مدير مكتب الجزيره ينضم الينا من جديد
مازن ابراهيم مبازن حتى اللحظه ما الذي
اسفرت عليه عنه هذه النتيجه
مخاض جديد محمد والان كل القوى السياسيه
ستنكد على قراءه متانيه للارقام التي حصلت
عليها ستحاول ان تفهم كيف حصلت بعض
المتغيرات تحديدا بما يتعلق بالكتله
المتردده الذي كان الحديث عن انها تضم نحو
28 نائبا ولكنها انخفضت الى 18 نائبا
توزعوا ما بين تصويت لزياده بارود او وضع
شعار لبنان الجديد او ورقه ملغات او ورقه
بيضاء وقائد الجيش اللبناني وبالتالي 18
اصوات توزعت بين
ازور وايضا سليمان فرنجيه وارتفعت ارقام
فرنجيه الى 51 وهذا ما لم يكن متوقعا ذلك
ان الكلام كان يجي عن سبعه واربعين لذلك
الان كل القوى السياسيه التي تقف على
الطرفين نقيض الاصطفاف القائم حاليا في
البرلمان ستحاول ان تشرح هذه الارقام كي
تبني على الامر مقتضاه خلال الفتره
المقبله ضمن التي ستبدا والتي ولا شك
بانها اعتبارا من اللحظه التي انفضت بها
جلسه اليوم ستبدا تلك المساومات في محاوله
للتوصل الى تسويات ما بين الاطراف
السياسيه او محاوله اعاده تموضع بعض
الاطراف وتغيير موقعها من طرف الى اخر من
هنا يمكن القول بان الرقم الذي حصل عليه
جهاد الزعول كان متوقعا 59 صوتا كان
الجميع يتحدث عن نحو 60 صوتا ايضا ارقام
سليمان افرنجيه زادت قليلا ولكنها ايضا
ضمن الهامش الذي كان متوقعا بينه وبين
ازعور وبالتالي على المستوى الاول الاطراف
التي رشحت جهاز ستقول بان هذا المرشح جدي
يمكن ان نتنازل عنه في مقبل الايام ولكن
لا يمكن القفز وراء القوى السياسيه التي
وقفت وراءه ودعمته بمعنى ان تملك نحو 60
صوتا في البرلمان وبالتالي من هنا ستبدا
قوى التيار الوطني الحر القوات اللبنانيه
الكتابه الاشتراكي وبعض المستقلين
المساومه
حزب الله في المرحله المقبله على المستوى
الثاني بالنسبه لحزب الله وحركه امل
سيقولون بان مرشحنا ايضا لديه تمثيل كبير
في البرلمان ولا يمكن القفز فوقه لذلك
ستفتح المسارات على عده احتمالات خلال
المرحله المقبله على مستوى التماسك في
التقاطع المسيحي الذي دفع بجهاد اشعور تمت
سؤال جدي هل سيستمر هذا التماسك بين هذه
القوه المتضاده بالسياسه وتحديدا ما بين
التيار الوطني الحر والقوات اللبنانيه هذا
من جهه وبالتالي هل سيستمرون بترشيح جهاد
الامس يطرحون اسما جديدا هذا على مستوى
الفريق المسيحي وحلفائه على المستوى
الثاني الى اي مدى هنالك سؤال الى اي مدى
يستعد مستعد حزب الله كي يتخلى عن سليمان
الفرنجيه في المرحله المقبله ام انه
سيستمر بتعطيل مع حلفائه الدوره الثانيه
من كل جلسه برلمانيه وبالتالي ندخل في نفق
طويل لذلك هنا تفتح قوه امام تدخلات
خارجيه من الواضح بانها ستبدا من خلال
حركه المفرد القادم والذي تم تعيينه من
قبل الرئيس الفرنسي وهو جائب الذي من
المفترض ان يصل الى بيروت خلال المرحله
المقبله وبالتالي ضمن هذه المتغيرات كلها
يمكن قول بان جلسه اليوم كانت بالغه
الاهميه لتحديد حجم كافه القوى وبالتالي
رسم نشاط سيبدا وخطوه الالف ستبدا اليوم
في محاوله البحث عن رئيس توافقي خلال
المرحله المقبله يعني اشرت مازن الى ان
الاسماء او الاسمين
ان الاسمين الاساسيين الذين طرحا اليوم
ليس نهائيا نهائيين يعني بمعنى وكانه ممكن
ان تختلف هذه الاسماء في الايام المقبله
كان هنالك عدد من الاصوات لزياد بارود وهو
وزير داخليه سابقه وايضا لقائد الجيش ما
الدلالات التي حملتها هذه الاوراق او هذه
الاصوات
ودلالات هذه الاسماء هل يمكن ان تشكل
مرشح جدي في المرحله الاولى في المرحله
المقبله
تماما فدا عندما تم ترشيح جهاد ازعور كان
الجميع عندما يترك ابواب القوى السياسيه
المرتبطه بترشيح جهاد الزهور كان يلمس في
كواليسها بان ترشيحها لجياده ازعور هو
ترشيح جدي في هذه الجلسه ولكنه قد لا
يستمر خلال المرحله المقبله قد لا تصرح
هذه القوى رسميا اليوم بانها ستتخلى عنه
وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لحزب الله الذي يقول
لانه يستمر بترشيح سليمان فرنجيه طالما ان
سليمان افرنجيه مستمر هو بترشيح نفسه
وبالتالي يمكن القول بانه خلال المرحله
المقبله نحن امام خيارين الخيار الاول اما
ان تتنازل كل القوى السياسيه عن مرشحيها
في المرحله المقبله وبالتالي البحث عن
نقطه التقاء لربما لربما يمكن القول بان
من دفع باسم زياد مرود وهو يحاول ان يصوك
زياد بارود علما بان التيار الوطني كان قد
طرحه سابقا وايضا من القى باسم قائد الجيش
اللبناني ضمن هذه الاصوات وهو ايضا يؤشر
الى ان ثمه
قرارات اخرى وان كانت غير مطروقه حاليا
وان كانت متروكه لمرحله مقبله وهو ما
تقوله اوساط ليست فقط داخليه ولكن تقاطعات
خارجيه اقليميه ودوليه تتحدث عن حدوث قائد
الجيش لذلك تماما في كما اشرت فان طرح
سليمان الفرنجي وجهات ازور هنالك من كان
يقول بان التعادل بينهما بمعنى التعادل
السلبي لما حصل كل منهما على هذه الاصوات
سيؤدي الى شطبهما خلال المرحله المقبله من
المعادله باتجاه التوصل الى تسويه بين
الاطراف لربما تنضج خلال الوسطات المترقب
المرتقبه خلال المرحله المقبله
زين لك مازن ابراهيم مدير مكتب الجزيره من
امام البرلمان في بيروت